good morning Hank it's Tuesday November
26 2013 I'm wearing a crumpled suit that
must mean it's time for the Bank of
nerdfighteria semi-annual report so it
just like tobyturner the Bank of
nerdfighteria has two arms and like Toby
Turner's arms they are rock-solid and
growing more powerful by the year let's
begin with the giving arm so every year
the nerdfighter community hosts
YouTube's project for awesome a 48 hour
event in which thousands of people
upload videos about their favorite
charities and then we watch and share
those videos but there's also a
fundraising component to the project for
awesome we raise money for the
foundation to decrease worldsuck and
then as a community we decide where to
donate it which helps us to think about
priorities and our values and the
importance of being thoughtful
philanthropists so last year we raised
more than four hundred thousand dollars
which went to organizations fighting
among other things illiteracy and
domestic violence and global poverty so
if you've never participated in the
project for awesome now is the time get
started on your videos for December 17th
uh I almost forgot the most important
thing Hank you and I are auctioning off
our support for World Cup 2014 there is
a link in the doobly-doo where you can
donate to the foundation to decrease
worldsuck
on behalf of the team of your choice and
we are going to support the teams that
nerdfighters donations choose top to
bottom so right now Germany is in fifth
place Netherlands is in seventh place in
total donations if Germany plays the
Netherlands we are for Germany and I
don't just mean that we will casually
root for the team in question we will
watch every single game and we will wear
the jersey of the teams we are
supporting and we will endeavor to learn
your soccer history and your songs and
try to watch live with you on Google+
Hangouts so please go donate it only
appears that I'm pointing at my pants
switzerland by the way is in last place
right now so get on it swiss people also
like in crazy good news the foundation
decrease worldsuck is now an official
501c3 federally sanctioned charity which
means that all donations in the US are
tax-deductible also every dollar that
you donate to the foundation or degrees
worldsuck will be matched this year up
to $125,000 thanks to some anonymous
donors right now the foundation to
decrease worldsuck has twenty three
thousand nine hundred and fifty five
dollars in the bank that's due to
donations from VidCon and from the
nerdfighter minecraft server and some
charity stuff at dftba.com so we're off
to a really great start
better than we were last year but
hopefully it is just the beginning now I
want to talk about the lending arm but
first I have to get on an airplane to go
see mom and dad hold on movie magic I'm
also a costume change oh my god I'm in
the exact same room where I filmed my
first episode of brother.a 2.0 on
January 2nd 2007 only now the walls are
different color and also painting by mom
okay on to the lending arm Hank over at
kiva.org the nerdfighter group has now
made more than 3.2 million dollars in
loans to students and entrepreneurs
around the world for instance
nerdfighters recently made a loan to
Alvaro in Bolivia to help him pay his
college tuition they made a loan to a
woman in Samoa so she can grow a
restaurant alone to a guy in Uganda so
he can grow his furniture business and
there are tens of thousands of others
through Kiva you can make loans of as
little as $25 to students and
entrepreneurs in the developing world
and 99% of the time they pay you back so
it's basically like I think a savings
account with a negative 1% interest rate
which is only 1% less than my bank is
currently offering so it's a pretty good
deal plus you get to invest in people's
businesses and watch them grow and the
coolest part is that if you're new to
Kiva your first loan is entirely free
link in the doobly-doo so like that's
the update on the Bank of nerdfighteria
when I was sitting here on January 2nd
2007 I could never have imagined that
the community that would grow out of
these videos would loan more than 3
million dollars or that the project for
awesome would be within shouting
distance of a million dollars in total
donations so I think I'm just so
grateful to nerdfighter for making it
happen and to you you're welcome back
surprise reunion video nerdfighters
again there are links in the doobly-doo
to lend and to donate I have a great
project for awesome DMD a Hank I'll see
you right now okay
oh and PS here's a picture of Matt Smith
doing the nerdfighter sign with some
Danish nerdfighters is this real life
what are you doing mom collects
kaleidoscopes no cool